a lawyer in south carolina is back
behind bars this morning alex murdoch
was denied bond yesterday over charges
that he stole millions after the
mysterious death of his housekeeper he's
also accused of trying to stage his own
suicide now back in june you may recall
that murdoch's wife and son were found
shot dead he is denied involvement in
their deaths nikki bates says following
this case nikki every time you hear some
something about this case it gets more
bizarre good morning to you good morning
gail you really can't make this up alex
murdock has been arrested twice in the
last five weeks tuesday's hearing
focused on murdoch's longtime family
housekeeper gloria satterfield who died
after an alleged slip and fall at
murdoch's home in 2018 no autopsy was
ever done and now south carolina
authorities are investigating her death
he stole he's a liar and a chief alex
murdock sat handcuffed in a south
carolina courtroom yesterday he is
accused of stealing millions from the
sons of his former housekeeper gloria
satterfield according to an arrest
warrant at the time of satterfield's
death murdoch allegedly told his
housekeeper's sons they would be taken
care of financially he provided the
children with a lawyer and even
suggested they sue him prosecutors now
allege murdoch kept most of the money
from the wrongful death settlement for
himself more than 3 million dollars the
death was first classified in natural
death
and there is nothing natural about a 57
year old woman falling down a flight of
steps and dying from head trauma
murdoch's past is mired with tragedy and
troubling incidents in june his wife
maggie and the couple's younger son paul
were shot and killed on the family's
sprawling south carolina hunting
property no suspect has been named in
that still open case in september
murdoch resigned from his own family law
firm after he was accused of stealing
money from the firm and its clients
murdoch claimed to have a 20-year opioid
addiction then a day later murdoch says
he asked his alleged drug dealer curtis
smith to shoot him so his surviving son
could inherit a 10 million life
insurance policy smith told us he
thought he was going to help murdoch
with some car trouble but murdock then
had a different request
he wanted me to kill him to make it look
like a suicide
man
on tuesday the judge ordered murdoch to
have a mental evaluation his lawyer said
he was more than happy to comply with
the request
the satterfield's lawyer told us they
have been able to retrieve some of the
missing funds and will continue to fight
until they get it all back alex
murdoch's lawyers did not respond to our
request for comments they feel for the
sadderfield family today because that
raises questions about her death as well
hasn't he been named a per mr murdoch
been named a person of interest in his
wife and his son's death alex they were
shot to death yes multiple times each
alex murdoch's lawyers say he is a
person of interest but authorities in
south carolina haven't confirmed that
yet but time will tell
there are no suspects yet in that case
complicated storyline that keeps
unfolding nikki thank you